hey guys what's up it's been quite a
while since we cover the topic about
middle-earth and there is quite a long
list of videos that we want to make for
you guys and if there are topics you
think are unique and you want us to make
then do put them down in the comment
section below also subscribe and hit the
notification bell for regular updates so
today we will be doing a topic on the
thirty animals found in middle-earth we
will be including the normal animals
that are also found in the real world
and also the fictional creatures that
are only found in middle-earth and Arda
as a whole we won't be including mire
spirits such as bare rocks and wizards
nor are we going to put in the different
sentient races like elves men dwarves
and orcs so anyway here is the list of
animals found in middle-earth number one
badges badges for mammals have dwelt in
middle-earth they were known in North as
being excellent hole diggers a
mysterious supposedly legendary race of
badges the Badger folk are mentioned in
The Hobbit verse in The Adventures of
Tom Bombadil the poem describes Tom
being captured by their leader named
badger Brock and subsequently being
released after friending them with one
of his magical chance
number two bats bats were large flying
creatures a Roman in forests of
middle-earth most bats were part of the
forest ecosystem however some bats were
bred from darkness and variants of
vampires and were known for their
service to the forces of darkness bat
sided with the offs and walks in the
Battle of the five armies during which
they flew so thickly across the sky that
the sunlight was blotted out number
three bears bears were native to the
Wilderland between the Misty Mountains
and MERP with very trifling ting however
they were not carnivores as was
demonstrated by the love of honey as the
bees of the will alone were at least
twice as big as average bees the Bears
were bound to have tough leathery skin
either as a natural attribute or from
adaptation to bee stings number four
Hawks
Hawks were large birds in row middle
earth as the Fellowship of the Ring was
being spied upon by the crew bein a lone
hawk was also thought as being a watcher
of the enemy meaning that
one may have used hops a spice as well
number five the great Eagles
the great Eagles were the messengers and
spies of the king of ardor and possessed
the ability to see through all physical
matter except for the blackness of more
God's evil pits in Peter Jackson's film
trilogies those of The Hobbit and The
Lord of the Rings the Eagles are smaller
than they are in the book however they
have been noted to be around six meters
or 20 feet tall with a wingspan of no
more than 23 metres or 75 feet number
six thrush a thrush is a slender small
to medium sized berth known for its a
harmonious song the stretch is said to
have belonged to an ancient breed known
by Thorens ancestors the men of day were
able to understand the language of the
bird and he served the men as messengers
a trash appears at the end of the film
The Hobbit an unexpected journey flying
to us a lonely mountain and begins
stopping a snail shell against the side
of the mountain
causing smoke to awaken number 7 Ravens
Ravens were large black birth of
middle-earth sometimes associated with
the ill news of death and were known for
their harsh voices the Ravens of Erebor
often brought secret news to the people
of thrall the king under the mountain
and in return they were rewarded with
bright objects to hide in the dwelling
dotted around ale at Raven Hill Ravens
could evidently live to a great age with
153 years being the oldest recorded
number 8 the Cree bein the cremains were
a species of large black crow like birds
native to both Dunnan and Fangorn forest
in middle-earth that Saruman the white
in Isengard uses a spice after he joined
forces with Sauron crew Bane were known
to fly in large flocks resembling a huge
black cloud and a big shadow cast below
them they made a horrible croaking
squawking noise when in flight which
makes their presence known to all near
them
number nine the Korean key the Korean
key was a small bird native to númenor
the Korean key were no bigger than wrens
they were scarlet coloured and with high
piping voices that men could barely hear
it is unknown what happened to them
whether Island was lost and they were
thought to have gone extinct with Newman
or number ten swans of all mo the swans
of Elmore were waterfowl of either black
or white color though usually the latter
intercept that the swans were especially
abundant in the nen in a blip the Swan
fleet a wetland region in area door the
Swan was an important bird in the tails
of the Ella days the Meyer or say said
many strong wing its wants to draw the
ships of the teller II over Bella gear
to a man without the help of the winds
number eleven the nightingales the
nightingales were small brown birds of
thrush kind famous for the clear singing
and for the fact that they would sing at
night as well as during the day the Maya
melian was said to always have
nightingales above her and they taught
them their songs it was the song of
these birds that and Janet Elway a lot
of the Tillery when he was wandering
alone in non elm earth after he came
upon Million number twelve foxes foxes
was four legged wild canines that lived
near the woods and while surrounding the
outskirts of the Shire
they were not known to be menacing and
probably avoided men and hobbits the
most famous of the mentioned foxes were
when they appeared and approached the
company of hobbits as they slept and the
words after they left the Shire
number 13 deers deers were four legged
beasts that inhabited middle-earth
mentioned in The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings deers were hunted for food by the
peoples of middle-earth save for the
burnings who did not eat meat deer came
in different coats including red and
white
the deers were common beasts of burden
for the elves Thranduil also wrote on
top of a great stack which kind of
looked like an Irish elk number 14
rabbits rabbits also known as hairs or
Kony's by hobbits were small fat animals
which lived all over middle-earth
rabbits were hunted for food by the
peoples of middle-earth usually when
traveling and not as butchers cuts
in Peter Jackson's movie the two towers
abrasive rabbits were caught by Gollum
just before a force of haradrim walked
through the land with an Oliphant number
15 horses horses were primary walking
and fighting animals in middle-earth
they were generally used as mounts both
forces of good and forces of evil used
them in the wars and battles of millard
in the Third Age Riders of Rohan and a
knight Nazgul were the most well known
for riding horses small horses were
called ponies horses came in many colors
such as white grey brown and black
number 16 cats cats was fought four
legged animals that lived in odda they
were often used as companions and pets
by the hobbits and the brief folk as
well they're keen sided and agile some
cats were used for hunting and spying
the cats of burrows real a unique type
of cats and during the turn age the
queen of Gondor kept nine black cats and
one white cat and the black cats fight
on the men of Gondor
number 17 dogs dogs were four-legged
beasts which were usually domesticated
in middle-earth they were closely
related to wolves and werewolves during
the Third Age beyond had several dogs
who could walk on their hind legs and
carry things with their forelegs they
could settle the table and were capable
of speech farmer maggot kept three dogs
grip Fang and wolf to God his farm
number 18 fish fish were coming through
other bodies of water in order fish were
animals of rivers Springs lakes and the
Great Sea they were often hunted for
food and in the case of Gollum they were
eaten raw as opposed to Gollum who ate
the raw fish hobbits specifically
Samwise Gamgee preferred cooked fish
there were innumerable species of fishes
in order 19 balls boys were wild picks
at row middle-earth
they had great jaws and they would use
for a weapon the most famous bore in
middle-earth was a great bore of ever
lot living in the fear in wood he was
hunted by falker the king of Rohan who
eventually killed him but was morally
wounded by the great beasts himself in
Peter Jackson's The Hobbit film trilogy
came to ironfoot arrive in the preload
of the bell of the
five armies astride a large boar number
20 wolves was for four-legged
carnivorous canines who lived in ara
during the first age there were many
subspecies of Millard apart from the
original gray wolves these groups
included the white wolves dogs
werewolves and walks wolf's like many
other animals in order had nothing to do
with naturally the forces of darkness
but serve in varying points throughout
the ages number 21
giant spiders giant spiders also known
as the children of ungoliant live
particularly in dark and perilous places
in middle-earth those who spoke were
vicious and malevolent creatures and
their presence was typically seen as
blight they live in the south of Miller
in the first age having descended from
the spider creature of the Eric gorath
but by the third age he spread to other
areas far away number 22 the kind of
arrow the kind of arrow were legendary
Carol like creatures are left around the
forest plains of the sea of roon from
the earliest days of odda onwards the
kind of era were descended from the even
greater kind kennel of aroma the hunter
who was known to be the master of beasts
and birds as Hiromi was chosen to lead
the else of the great journey
he might have intentionally left his
livestock in the east
number 23 the mirrors the mirrors were a
breed of wild horses in north of
middle-earth they surpassed normal
horses in their intelligence speed and
strength according to law the ancestors
of the mirrors were brought from the
west by aroma during the Third Age
Candace was given consent to write
Shadowfax the Lord of the Mira's Sheriff
acts continued to accompany Gandalf
throughout the latter half of the war of
the ring number 24 the Mumma kill the
mimic you will large creatures
resembling elephants often used in
battle by the haradrim mimic kills have
an appearance at kindred air of an
elephant spotting thick arrow resistant
skin and four curved tusks
plus two smaller toes behind that larger
pair the miracles most defining feature
is undoubtedly their vast size allowing
the armies of Mordor to erect watch
hours on their backs
miracles are roughly eight times larger
than a real-world elephant
number 25 the fell bees the fell bees
were described as large winget creatures
without feathers that have pinions in
between their haunt fingers and whose
bodies give off a stench it is possible
that fel bees came in from an older
world
the Dark Lord Sauron brettly's fel bees
and gave them to his servants there is a
common misconception that these
creatures are called nazgûl probably due
to the fact that the unit in many other
video games were named as such number26
walks walks were a breed of wolves in
middle-earth who lived in the Misty
Mountains and were captured and used
specifically by the orcs of Isengard and
Mordor in a Third Age the walks were not
specifically evil themselves they were
known to be exclusively used alongside
by goblins sometimes as the nest deeds
they appear first in The Hobbit
attacking Turin and company as they
travel east from the Misty Mountains
number 27 the drakes of Mordor the
drakes of mortal our breed created by
Sauron and they are infidel dragon fell
beast crosses hybridized by the Dark
Lord in the pits of bara door notable
characteristics of drakes include spiky
protrusions on the lower jaw back and
belly and on the tip of their tails
additionally there is a skull like bony
crests covering the upper jaw and face
would small rather black looking eyes
drapes do not have vivid horns on their
heads as dragons do but they have large
jaws resembling those of crocodiles
number 28 dragons dragons were
long-lived powerful cunning possessed of
subtle intelligence and had great
physical strength and were covered in
nearly impenetrable scales everywhere
except their undersides they also
possess an overwhelming greed for
treasure especially gold and when well
known for sleeping on piles of stolen
treasure by the very nature they
relished not only the death of beautiful
things but the act of dispossession
itself number 29
we're worms the real worms were
creatures of an unknown kind possibly
mythical and presumably related to
dragons that was said to dwell in the
last desert the real worms were only
mentioned once so almost nothing is
known about them until they were seen in
the third part of the Hobbit trilogy the
it's had a rich folklore about full of
fantastic creatures and we're worms
quite possibly fall into that category
number 30 the ruin the woman was a great
whale that served Olmo being entitled as
a primeval whale hugglemas great whale
with gilma being an early name for all
mo or the oldest of the right whales
moon was the oldest and - of all whales
who win has a Titanic strength as his
large tail lash was described to be
unmeasured to cause the sea to wrath
alongside with almost trumpet well that
brings us to the end of the video so do
subscribe for more related content on
creatures and monsters